[Música]
hoy en el debate de France 24 vamos a
hablar de Venezuela allí el entonces
ministro de petróleo estará el aissami
renunció a su cargo que era tal vez uno
de los más importantes O al menos así lo
era cuando Venezuela mantenía una enorme
industria petrolera que se ha
desmoronado con el paso de los años pero
bueno esa es otra historia la renuncia
de El aissami tiene lugar en el marco de
una serie de investigaciones por
corrupción una investigación por parte
del Ministerio Público debido a indicios
de graves hechos de corrupción no
solamente en la codiciada pedevesa la
compañía Estatal de petróleos sino
también en otras entidades estatales
Entonces nos preguntamos a Qué niveles
llega la corrupción en el gobierno
venezolano en la actualidad daré que
laissami que representa o qué
representaba en esa estructura del
chavismo madurismo hay purgas internas
en el gobierno venezolano y tiene esto
algo que ver con una especie de lavado
de imagen de cara a esas elecciones
presidenciales del 2024 son tan solo
algunas de las preguntas que dejamos
sobre la mesa para el debate por eso hoy
en nuestro programa Aquí en France 24
Venezuela una purga anticorrupción para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a José
Vicente carrasquero él es analista
político y docente de la universidad
Simón Bolívar se encuentra en la ciudad
de Miami en Estados Unidos y desde
Bogotá en Colombia se conecta Alejandro
Cardozo usátegui él Es doctor en
historia politólogo y también profesor
de política y relaciones internacionales
de la universidad Sergio arboleda que
está ubicada en la ciudad de Bogotá en
Colombia recuerden ustedes nuestros
televidentes que también hacen parte de
este debate ustedes pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales nos encuentran en
Twitter en Facebook y en instagram nos
encuentran allí como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate f24
y a mí me encuentran en Twitter como
arro ba santilogo no olviden también que
todos los contenidos de nuestro programa
están disponibles en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
de hoy entonces la bienvenida a José
Vicente en la ciudad de Miami Gracias
por estar con nosotros José Vicente
Bienvenido al programa y Punto de
partida para la discusión y el análisis
Qué sensación y qué perspectiva le deja
usted la renuncia de tarea que laissami
bueno
él salvoconducto que él mismo se ha
otorgado fíjense que hay cantidad de
gente detenida en esta operación pero
nadie sabe el paradero para que
sobre él todo apunta que no va a recaer
mayor castigo es uno de los Ungidos de
la Revolución y en ese sentido No creo
que va a estar fuera de los castigos en
todo caso
estar fuera no quiere decir que no tenga
una responsabilidad porque uno de los
principales implicados es un compañero
de estudios de adolescencia hasta la
universidad una persona que se trajo a
trabajar con él muy de cerca es muy
difícil pensar que una persona tan
cercana pudiera estar cometiendo actos
de corrupción sin que el ministro
estuviese enterado sobre todo conociendo
el pasado de que no es precisamente el
de una de un santo varón sino que se le
conocen ciertos
desmanes y ciertos comportamientos
no precisamente alineados con la
conducta de una persona honesta paso a
saludar ahora a Alejandro Cardozo en la
ciudad de Bogotá Alejandro Gracias por
estar con nosotros y el mismo Punto de
partida Cuál es su sensación su
perspectiva de la renuncia del ex
ministro de laisami bienvenido
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación
coincido con con el profesor carrasquero
es improbable que caiga sobre él lo
inmediato
que un castigo digamos por medio
de la estructura formales de los
mecanismos de Justicia venezolanos pero
pienso que es un ajuste
efectivamente
pienso También que hay muchísima
incidencia en el proyecto de de poder de
los hermanos Rodríguez
El aissami representa una visión
geopolítica muy distinta y muy contraria
lo que quieren los hermanos Rodríguez
para el futuro sobre todo petrolero de
Venezuela ellos quieren abrirse hacia
Estados Unidos hacia Europa hacia China
y el adisami por sus propias por su
propio contexto como perseguido de la
justicia internacional como perseguido
del departamento de estado del
departamento del tesoro estadounidense
pues es la preferido entonces jugar a
una paridad diplomacia
es decir mantener los lazos y
fortalecerlos cada vez más que se pueda
con eurasia con aquella parte del mundo
que está un poco lejos de la justicia
estadounidense yo creo que Entonces en
ese sentido el aissami cuya carrera ha
sido astronómica ha sido una carrera
política muy rápida desde el presidente
del centro de estudiantes de la escuela
de derechos de la facultad de derecho y
de ciencias políticas en Mérida hasta
llegar a presidente pereza Sí esa
carrera astronómica pues tiene sus
cuotas de de poder y ese es el poder que
se están disputando Entonces
ese es mi hasta ese hasta este punto Ese
es mi panorama de de de de las
acusaciones que caen sobre él y sobre su
equipo
Aparentemente sale ahora de la escena
política venezolana Alejandro continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
Pero quién es y que representa en la
estructura actual del chavismo madurismo
quién es y qué representa la figura del
aissami entendiendo Pues que este
capítulo se cierra por lo menos hasta
acá su paso por pedevesa finaliza acá y
no sabemos si más adelante pueda tener
otro tipo de
función dentro de la política venezolana
pero por el momento ahora que sale de la
vida pública que es parte del eslabón de
la estructura pertenece a él
los sistemas alianzas
Son cambiados son muy biológicos son
cambiantes sin embargo mantienen ciertas
tendencias firme el aissami recordemos
que es heredero de su grupo de poder y y
su historia en el poder en Venezuela
está directamente comprometido con la
historia de él es una figura altamente
su mejor digamos su mejor balance de
poderlo obtuvo durante Durante los
tiempos de Chávez él es un superviviente
del nuevo algoritmo que quiere Tal vez
tal vez acaso posiblemente construir
maduro con los hermanos Rodríguez que
son Realmente los los cerebros de de
esta nueva fase que no echa vista que es
madurista Entonces en ese reacomodo de
fuerzas podríamos ubicar a tareck en
herencia de las cuotas de poder
otorgadas durante el chavismo y toda su
relación con Siria a pesar de que el
papá de tarek fue perseguido de de
bachera al azar un perseguido
en Siria sí pero a pesar de eso
recordemos que su padre fue presidente
de la asociación de no de la liga
socialista árabe en América Latina él
hereda digamos toda esa todos esos
vínculos con con la paria diplomacia no
con eurasia y los ha reforzado Entonces
ese momento digamos paria diplomático
de la política exterior del chavismo
madurismo le dio también cuotas de poder
al mismo tiempo el heredó muchísimas de
esas cuotas durante chavismo su ascenso
astronómico y él pertenece a un grupo
que es él es él y sus como lo dijo el
profesor carrasquero su compañero de
carrera upbel Roa y el gobernador actual
de Mérida todos los que estaban
posicionados el gobernador del estado
sucre lo que estaban posicionados en
diferentes empresas estatales
venezolanas estratégicas como la de
criptoactivos etcétera son las cuotas de
poder aquel que él y su grupo que es el
que está siendo golpeado actualmente
representan en esa digamos en esa
geometría sí Alejandro de de fuerzas en
el chavismo madurismo José Vicente le
doy la palabra su opinión sobre lo que
representa a tareas que laisami en la
estructura política de Venezuela en la
actualidad hasta este punto que renuncia
no no mucho más no mucho más que
agregarte lo que dijo el doctor
Alejandro En todo caso recordar que uno
de los que trae a Venezuela de
que se encarga de fortalecer los lazos
de Venezuela con Palestina es también
lo pueden trae una un distanciamiento de
Venezuela con el estado de Israel y eso
Por supuesto ha tenido una repercusiones
bastante graves sobre la credibilidad de
Venezuela desde el punto de vista
ejercicio de la política internacional
en todo caso Yo quisiera agregar en este
mismo sentido que este
asunto que se Está realizando con tarea
que yo para mí parte de un de un Una
tarima más amplia que viene también
desde el Foro de Sao Paulo esa
preocupación que le genera al resto de
los países del foro y líderes del foro
de Sao Paulo que cada vez que hay una
elección en los distintos países
Venezuela aparece como Ese lunar negro
el socialismo del Siglo 21 como es el
lunar negro El progresismo de que se
quiera adelantar desde el foro Sao Paulo
y ha habido requerimiento de estos del
presidente Lula y del presidente Petro a
maduro de lavar un poco el rostro de el
sistema político venezolano de tal forma
de presentar lo más potable sí hacia el
mundo y que no haya más Venezuela en los
procesos electorales sí que siempre se
pone como ejemplo de un intento bastante
particular de establecer Un gobierno
socialista
apalancado en una cantidad de recursos
naturales que como decíamos en la
introducción pues hoy en día Venezuela
no tiene la capacidad de producir la
cantidad de petróleo que producía unas
décadas atrás Hablemos del tema central
que nos lleva Más allá de la renuncia de
del aissami allí en Venezuela es este
marco de esta operación anticorrupción
que tiene en marcha el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro en un país donde muchos
critican la la diferencia de poderes y
en un país donde el gobierno tampoco
rinde cuentas A qué niveles llega la
corrupción en el gobierno de Venezuela a
Qué niveles llega la corrupción en la
cotidianidad de Venezuela cuando sé que
es muy difícil medirlo o establecerlo
porque no hay una institución que haga
una evaluación de esas o si la hay pues
no presentan las los resultados de este
tipo de evaluaciones como hacen otro
tipo de gobiernos José Vicente para
hacer la la ronda la inversa
Hasta qué grado está en que está la
corrupción
Sí bueno lo primero que tú te tienes que
preguntar es Dónde están los sobrinos
sabes ni liberados por los Estados
Unidos si cometieron un crimen en
Estados Unidos en un crimen que se
estaba cometiendo en Venezuela que hizo
Venezuela con ellos nada lo metieron un
escaparate seguramente están disfrutando
de las piezas que ofrece el país este
están en una libertad bastante reservada
pero en todo caso este Venezuela tenía
que haber tomado algunas medidas con
respecto a estos señores uno se puede
preguntar por ejemplo cuánto paga El
Dorado cabello por el tiempo de
televisión que utiliza en venezolanos de
televisión que se supone que es el canal
de todos los venezolanos y él tiene un
programa de televisión a cuenta de que o
sea que en sus funciones políticas lo
hace el acreedor de un programa de
televisión
después tú te pones a analizar la forma
como se viste la señora Rodríguez como
seguiste el señor Rodríguez y tú te vas
a dar cuenta de que ellos no salen a la
calle con menos de dos tres mil dólares
encima el reloj el el el el Rolex que
tiene muchas veces Nicolás maduro y tú
te preguntas bueno Con qué salario de
esos míseros salarios que ganan en
Venezuela inclusive Los Altos cargos del
estado se pueden comprar estos ajuares
entonces tú ves que la corrupción está
en el ADN del chavismo el solo hecho de
tu haber comprometido el cuatro de
febrero de 1992 a unos soldados a una
misión engañados llevándolos diciéndoles
que iban a hacer algo que no era lo que
iban a hacer Ya te implica este los
niveles de corrupción que estaban ahí en
el tuétano del chavismo el chavismo es
una estructura vertical y
transversalmente corrupta
una verdadera lucha contra la corrupción
pasaría por sacarlos a todos ellos de
posiciones Alejandro viendo en
perspectiva no solamente Venezuela la
corrupción es un mal digamos que
transversal para todos los países en
América Latina es una gran lucha la que
hacen los diferentes gobiernos contra
contra este flagelo tampoco es una
novedad a lo largo de las décadas lo
hemos visto la corrupción en pedevesa
tampoco es una novedad la corrupción en
Venezuela esto es como lo digo
particular para la región de América
Latina donde los índices de corrupción
son muy altos pero el mismo ex
presidente Chávez decía en su momento
que la corrupción era un cáncer y ya el
gobierno del chavismo y el madurismo
lleva muchas décadas se puede decir que
también falló en esta lucha contra la
corrupción de la que supuestamente era
abanderados en su momento
no solo falló solo fracasó sino que
inventó nuevas formas de corrupción
la nueva formas de corrupción y nuevas
formas de hacer imperceptible el daño
moral a la nación los hechos corruptos
es impresionante Como cada vez más el
pueblo venezolano tolera los excesos
visuales que el profesor que respiro
hace referencia no en el vestir etcétera
En el modo de vida Esa nomenclatura esa
élite No pero fíjate que yo creo que una
de las de los castigos del fracaso de la
de la de los castigos de derivados del
fracaso de la lucha contra la corrupción
es este pequeño anécdota que cuento
brevísimamente uno cuando roba que es el
primero que cae digamos dentro de la
estructura de El aissami cuando fue
ministro de ciencia y tecnología
Él y su tren ministerial se llevaron
inclusive el tope de granito del
despacho del ministro
enajenaron todos los bienes vehiculares
es decir todos los carros la flota del
carro fue enajen rematada se robaron
cualquier cantidad de cosas inclusive de
los enseres de toda la vida de ese
edificio es decir es una corrupción en
todos los niveles y yo creo que eso fue
una de las de las piedras de toque para
esta activar digamos esta operación
contra el grupo del aissami porque
aparte de de de todo el daño y el el
perjuicio moral que significan estos
hechos la ministra que estaba tomando el
manto en ese momento la que recibe
digamos el despacho de
ella misma estuvo a punto de denunciar
estos centros de corrupción ante el
sebin ante el servicio de inteligencia
política del chavismo porque era dejó
absolutamente quebrado en bancarrota a
ese ministerio y eso es uno un personaje
que era el número dos después de tarek
que ya como lo ha descrito el profesor
carrasquero es una nomenclatura y una
élite que ya está enriquecida y sin
embargo siguen
drenando la forma de cualquier forma
enriquecimiento de la nación entonces la
lucha no fue solo un fracaso sino que se
instauró una nueva cultura de la
corrupción e inclusive Me atrevo a decir
otra cosa la corrupción ha sido la
amalgama diplomática para llevar
relaciones con por ejemplo con Rusia la
cantidad de ventures que se han hecho de
empresas que se han hecho con el
gobierno del kremling y con Venezuela
Son increíbles gastro para América
Latina
toda la trama de los aparatos de energía
portátil de estas plantas de
electrificación después del fracaso
también de la política energética de las
represas y de los generadores de de los
bloques de poder en la electricidad
venezolana se hicieron con Rusia es
decir la la corrupción no fue solo un
fracaso sino que se reinventa y se
internacionalizadas y no digamos
lo mismo lo mismo que ellos criticaron
durante tantos años terminaron
prácticamente potenciando lo llevándolo
a unas a unos niveles insospechados
Aquí voy a citar a uno de los líderes
opositores Enrique capriles que a través
de su cuenta de Twitter dijo en José
Vicente dijo lo siguiente lejos de ser
un acto de Justicia esta operación
anticorrupción es un ajuste de cuentas
entre la cúpula que detenta el poder se
están peleando el botín y no les importa
el sufrimiento del pueblo esto nos lleva
a un punto interesante para debatir y Es
sobre si hay o no disputas internas
dentro del madurismo y dentro del
chavismo porque pensaría uno que con una
infraestructura y un partido político
que domina prácticamente todas las
instancias del Estado domina todas las
instancias de la vida de Venezuela
pensaría uno que está bastante
cohesionado y donde se respetarían muy
bien los diferentes roles precisamente
para poder mantener a flote toda esa
infraestructura que ellos han montado a
lo largo de estos años para mantenerse
en el poder
Bueno fíjate cuando tú tienes que poner
a un general de división comandante de
un cuerpo de la Aviación
venezolana a explicarle a los señores
que tienen que
dedicarse Al enfrentamiento al
emprendimiento para poder balancear Los
sueldos cuando se sabe que a los pilotos
de esa fuerza aérea se les pagan 800
dólares mensuales fuera de su salario
que es un miserable y casi inexistente
tú te estás dando cuenta de que hay
lunares que marcan un descontento
lunares que marcan un desencuentro con
la forma como se ha venido manejando el
país no hemos mencionado una una gran
parte de ese chavismo que estuvo con
Chávez y que hoy en día no está con
maduro y ahí están el profesor Héctor
Navarro los equipos yo mencionando a lo
grande no y otros personas que están ahí
que se han separado
de esta forma de hacer política tan
descarada tan grosera que no tiene como
objetivo el bienestar de la gente tiene
más bien como objetivo el usufructo de
los bienes del Estado para los fines
particulares de lo que ellos llaman
revolución y para las relaciones que
puedan tener este con la con la estas
diplomacia paria que menciona el doctor
Alejandro entonces ante lo que estamos
en una situación fuera de ahí que nos
está llevando Mira te lo digo
rápidamente nosotros estamos recibiendo
un grupo en los ambos dedicado a esto
estamos recibiendo cantidad de denuncias
con respecto a las cementeras y como él
se ponen ahí sobre precios y se reparten
ellos el cemento y lo venden a los
precios que le da la gana estamos
recibiendo denuncias sobre alcaldías
específicas en el estado aragua en
Mérida este estamos recibiendo cantidad
de denuncias de las cosas que están
pasando en Venezuela donde la corrupción
ha llegado a límites insospechados donde
en la demostración de riqueza es una
cuestión verdaderamente grosera por ahí
salen los videos de una señora que
supuestamente era la pareja de Júpiter
arroba o se llama el señor que son
verdaderamente
descarado que claman ante los ojos de
Dios Entonces este yo sí creo que es ahí
fisuras en el chavismo Y esa fisuras van
a necesitar de que su ente rector es el
gobierno cubano una forma más clara de
control de esta situación Alejandro
teniendo entonces claro este panorama
que nos explica José Vicente Cómo serían
esas disputas aquí habría digamos tipo
algunos tipos de grupos dentro del
madurismo que se están disputando
puestos dentro de esa jerarquía o qué
figuras clave estarían tratando de
enfrentarse a otras al interior del
partido y bueno del gobierno
evidentemente hay grupos
Solo que hay que tipificarlos como a
veces
híbridos y siempre cambiantes no en sus
alianzas sino en sus modos operandi o en
sus eh vamos a decirlos en sus trueques
en sus trueques y e intercambios de
cuotas de poder pero el grupo más
poderoso son los hermanos Rodríguez
actualmente Jorge Rodríguez y delsi
Rodríguez no solamente por las carteras
que llevan que son sumamente sensibles
sino también porque llevan bueno llevan
la carretera política exterior y bueno
la cartera legislativa sino por la
capacidad de decisión que tienen no
hay una cosa que hay que mencionar desde
la virtud de la ciencia política Es
decir desde la evidencia ellos han sido
muchísimo menos escandalosos en en los
actos de corrupción que el grupo de
Target por ejemplo Y eso los ha
beneficiado de alguna forma y sobre todo
los envalentonados para esta Cruzada
luego está el grupo
que siempre lo vinculan a a digamos al
grupo castrense que es diosdado cabello
que Dios ha dado cabello
En algunos momentos fue Aliado y En
algunos momentos fue desafiante al poder
de tarek pero coincidieron en en
momentos estratégicos como equipo luego
está por supuesto que maduro y Siria lo
mucho lo reconocen como un equipo
autónomo aparte
es el presidente Sí pero digamos en las
cuotas de poder de la herencia de una
presidencia que no fue tan legítima y
tan popular como la de Chávez ellos
representan digamos un grupo central sin
embargo es difícil desvincularlos de los
hermanos Rodríguez y la cantidad de
tareas que el presidente maduro le ha
otorgado a los hermanos Rodríguez y
ellos son digamos que nos recuerdan un
poco a la década de los ochenta a esta
las escuelas monetaristas Pues
neoliberales que querían pues hacer la
economía más eficiente etcétera no bajo
el servicio de salarios de sacrificio
del bienestar social me recuerdan un
poco a esa doctrina no de la economía
ellos quieren ir hacia una economía un
poco más eficiente en Venezuela etcétera
y maduro estaba pues bastante satisfecho
con ellos desvincular a dentro del punto
de vista de Alianza y de amistad atares
con maduro es complicado pero yo creo
que maduro pues aplicó la máxima de la
razón de estado respecto a su amistad o
su histórica Alianza contraria Al haber
permitido esta jugada de ajedrez de los
hermanos Rodríguez sí de pues ir a por
ir a por tarek y su equipo no entonces
ya con este gesto podríamos identificar
el grupo de los hermanos Rodríguez y el
grupo de diosdado cabello bastante
inferior Pero dentro de esa repartición
de fuerzas junto con el grupo maduro
Silvia como los tres hegemónicos Claro
en este momento político de Venezuela
José Vicente si usted quiere Añadir algo
en torno a esta especie de estructura
que nos explicó Alejandro para entender
cómo están allí la carga le doy espacio
para que lo haga y le añado también la
pregunta y subo esto un poco a otro
nivel al nivel de lo que significa la
revolución como tal esa Revolución
socialista allí en Venezuela si esto ya
tiene fisuras y están empezando a
abrirse grietas y hay una necesidad por
parte de cualquiera que esté en el poder
de empezar a hacer cambios de fondo para
poder sostener este andamiaje de lo que
ha significado la revolución bolivariana
en Venezuela
Bueno lo primero que hay que decir es
que la revolución nunca existió en lo
que hubo fue un intento de hacerse del
poder a toda costa de eliminar cualquier
posibilidad de cosas que balancearan el
poder entonces tú ahí tienes que incluir
el poder que tiene Silvia flores que lo
mencionó Alejandro sobre el el poder
judicial el poder que adquieren ahora
sobre la procuraduría sobre la
contraloría sobre la fiscalía todos los
poderes en Venezuela son unas especies
de secretarías del partido de gobierno Y
eso Por supuesto hace que sea muy
difícil llevar adelante en ningún caso
independiente en Venezuela
yo dije un poco de Alejandro con
respecto a la al castigo
iba a seguir indemne de esto por ahora
nadie sabe dónde está
muy difícil que la policía que es capaz
de capturar a todo el mundo en todos
había hecho este tipo de rebajada no
haya Atrapado hasta ahora a a estar y el
mismo maduro dijo que este
había reconocido su compromiso con la
Revolución y la revolución es igual que
la revolución cubana una entelequia una
cuestión que no existe una cuestión
alrededor de la cual lo hago funcionar
todo como un Destino final es la
sustitución de Dios por la revolución lo
que se le critica lo que criticaba Marx
a las religiones que era lo peor del
pueblo Bueno lo peor del pueblo ahorita
es la revolución una Revolución que no
le ha dejado nada y se mantiene a la
población esperando ese gran puerto de
llegada de una Revolución donde hay una
supuesta renovación completa de todo que
Cuba Lleva más de seis décadas esperando
llegar a ese puerto fantástico que
vendió la la revolución en su momento le
hago la pregunta a Alejandro en torno a
la revolución como tal la misma pregunta
Usted cree que esto ya el andamiaje está
empezando a sufrir una necesidad de
ajuste de las tuercas puede ser
sostenible ya llevan más de más de 20
años más de dos décadas de revolución
bolivariana que tanto puede sostenerse
esto
Mira la mejor metáfora para describir la
revolución bolivariana es Irán en qué
sentido Venezuela durante estos veinte
años de revolución chavista
a sintetizado la historia del chat de
Irán una historia de corrupción de
desmadre del gasto Público de
ostentación Absurda de la riqueza
con la revolución de la ayatola y sus
vicios
autoritarios terribles persecutores
incluso de la mujer
en ese sentido Venezuela la revolución
chavista yo la describiría como una
mezcla un monstruo híbrido entre el chat
de Irán y el ayatola y los ayatola
cumplen las las mismas cumplen los
mismos vicios las mismas negaciones
hacia la democracia hacia libertad hacia
la libertad etcétera violan los mismos
derechos humanos y ostentan la riqueza
como la ostentaba el chat reza y su y su
corte No ese para mí es es eso para mí
se simplifica Yo sé que en televisión el
tiempo es corto y no podría decir otra
cosa más larga pero que ella esté
sufriendo los como dices tú la presión
de su sistema se esté venciendo en este
momento no creo porque han tenido la
astucia de reinventarse y esta
persecución a tarek es un reinvento yo
coincido con el profesor carrasquero no
sé si a tare que venga un destino bajo
rejas pero creo en la imaginación No
creo la imaginación y y pienso que a
veces he imaginado atare como un factor
inclusive de cambio con Estados Unidos
porque eso es una pieza muy estorbosa
para el proyecto de los hermanos
Rodríguez y pienso que puede ser
inclusive una pieza de Arcángel en un
contexto todavía de mayor presión sobre
inclusive de cáncer Recuerden que aunque
quería capturar Estados Unidos
Sí usted toca un punto muy importante y
justo Esa era la pregunta que les iba a
hacer a los dos Es sobre esto que imagen
le está dando de Venezuela a Estados
Unidos es un pequeño guiño de maduro a
Estados Unidos porque el servicio de
migración y control de aduanas de ese
país norteamericano incorporó a tereque
laisami en su lista de 10 Fugitivos más
buscados en el año 2020
entonces pues ahí hay un hay un
conflicto con con was hington esto es
una especie de guiño de coqueteo con
Estados Unidos demostrar que se está
recuperando ciertos digámoslo entre
comillas valores democráticos en esta
persecución contra la corrupción y que y
que se están moviendo fichas que que hay
que mover para mostrarse así un poco más
democráticos ante el mundo cómo lo ve
usted José Vicente
en un despliegue clásico de pragmatismo
norteamericano la Casa Blanca ayer dijo
que recibía con beneplácito las
investigaciones de corrupción que se
estaban haciendo en Venezuela a ese
mismo gobierno al que no le reconozco su
legitimidad a ese mismo gobierno al cual
le aplico sanciones le Reconozco que
esté haciendo una lucha por la
corrupción yo de verdad no sé si esto
tiene que ver con el desconocimiento que
tienen estos funcionarios de la
situación venezolana o hay simplemente
el cinismo llevado a su máxima expresión
ciertamente que lo que ha estado
tratando fuertemente Venezuela de hacer
es de congraciarse de alguna manera con
el gobierno de los Estados Unidos en la
medida que las sanciones realmente han
tenido este una
una fuerza muy grande sobre todo sobre
la industria
sobre Irán que tiene muchas más
sanciones que Venezuela entonces este
este asunto llama la atención y parece
alinear los deseos de los hermanos
Rodríguez con lo que está pensando el
gobierno norteamericano además que sea
alguien que le interesa nuevamente la
industria petrolera de Venezuela es
Estados Unidos y quien tal vez podría
ponerla otra vez en marcha es Estados
Unidos Rusia en este momento creo que
tiene intereses mucho más importantes en
su situación internacional y en su
situación con Ucrania y China pues se ha
mostrado un poco más distante de Caracas
porque ya acumulan una deuda estos dos
países bueno Venezuela le debe no le
alcanzará la vida ni el petróleo para
pagarle la deuda a China de la cantidad
de préstamos que ha recibido Esto me
lleva a preguntarle a Alejandro sobre el
escenario electoral del 2024 esto
también puede ser parte de un lavado de
imagen de mostrar al gobierno de maduro
un poco más comprometido con con esta
lucha contra la corrupción que es uno de
los grandes reclamos de los ciudadanos
de quienes permanecen allí Porque
recordemos casi siete millones de
venezolanos han dejado el país están
esparcidos por el mundo en búsqueda de
nuevas oportunidades y rehaciendo su
vida
desde luego desde luego es un es una lo
han dicho en el programa es una una
lavada de cara importante de Cara a las
elecciones de frente a las elecciones
venideras
yo creo que Venezuela es un
autoritarismo competitivo pleno tengo
muy pocas esperanzas en unas elecciones
abiertas pero sin embargo tomando en
cuenta que haya cierta competitividad en
en las elecciones con candidatos
outsiders o con segundos actores no
totalmente aceptado y legitimados por
las fuerzas opositoras si se da ese
escenario desde luego que la lucha
contra esta esta lucha pues contra el
grupo de tares y y los casos que ya
hemos determinado de presos y de
detenidos pues ha mejorado pues va a
mejorar la imagen del país y otra cosa
va a mejorar el escenario para que
maduro pueda hablar de elecciones es
decir la comunidad internacional la
opinión pública mundial y de la Casa
Blanca
van a ver y desde la oea desde todos los
foros que se están reactivando como
celac unasura etcétera van a ver que la
casa se está limpiando Entonces en ese
sentido Pues el escenario un escenario
electoral así sea muy controlado por por
el gobierno actual va a ser más
agradable para los que están mirando
desde afuera un posible escenario de
me quedaron un par de minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero que hagamos
las conclusiones comienzo entonces con
José Vicente para darle la palabra su
conclusión lo que deja esta renuncia de
este ex ministro de petróleos allí en
Venezuela lo que significa esto de aquí
en adelante lo que puede venir para este
país en el marco de esta operación
anticorrupción
Bueno yo yo quiero insistir en que esto
es una cuestión que estaba más bien
asociada a la necesidad que tiene
Venezuela de cumplir con las demandas
que vienen de la visita del presidente
Petro de las conversaciones con nura da
Silva de que y con las conversaciones
con el presidente de México de que hay
que cambiar la imagen de Venezuela Esto
está encausado por ahí sin embargo yo sí
creo que la esta castigos entre comillas
tendrá un efecto más bien en los
seguidores de Chávez en aquellos que
sean cercanos a maduro
de ahí en adelante es muy difícil que
esto sobrepase la malísima la pésima
calidad de vida que tienen los
venezolanos en estos momentos que
compara esa calidad de vida con la que
puede estar la gente en Haití y eso ya
es una cuestión bastante grave pasar
sobre eso
requiere unos niveles de eficacia y
deficiencia que veo a maduro incapaz de
alcanzar de Alejandro su conclusión para
el cierre
para usar algo distinto
yo concluyo que tarek se volvió un
obstáculo representa muchísimos desafíos
para la política exterior venezolana se
volvió un obstáculo había que quitarlo
del medio y Definitivamente ya con esto
cierro tenemos que decir tarek fue un
funcionario muy deficiente muy
ineficiente sus equipos de trabajo sus
gestiones en diferentes Arenas del poder
en Venezuela fueron pésimas fueron
pésimas Y en esa medida también pues fue
juzgado además de corrupto además de
llevar a cabo una pared diplomacia con
escolar con irán con grupos muy
contrarios al proyecto de reconexión
global que quieren llevar a cabo los
hermanos Rodríguez tarek también era un
funcionario ineficiente muy ineficiente
Alejandro ya José Vicente les agradezco
mucho por haber hecho este análisis para
la audiencia de France 24 en América
Latina Muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros es todo por el momento a
ustedes Muchas gracias por la sintonía y
En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos haber estado con nosotros la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera sigan
con nosotros sigan dejando comentarios
en las redes sociales
[Música]